as podcast has bad words hello everybody
welcome to the minimalist podcast where
we discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn and I'm Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists indeed we are welcome to
episode 130 today we're gonna talk about
food and if we're talking about food
I figure we bring a friend back on to
the show we don't do interviews and we
rarely do guests but occasion will bring
a friend on to help us answer some
questions and today we're here with rich
row ladies and gentlemen rich roll so
good to be with you guys man good yeah
awesome the last time I did this was a
live show at the at the Fillmore and
doing our Francisco that was by far I
think my favorite show because because
you were there obviously of course and
that stage man like I just cannot
believe how many stinking artists and
bands have like been on that stage it
was it was truly an honor to be on there
man like it's by far my favorite of all
yeah it was awesome well let's so for
those of you who want to listen to that
previous conversation we did in San
Francisco and thanks for flying out for
that it was you came up like straight up
from Miami I think was that right I
think so but I just you know the
opportunity presented itself and I was
like yeah I'll do that like the film or
of course brother is so iconic man it
was yeah and then a few months ago well
actually go back to the beginning but
but a few months ago we filmed our
second documentary at least a talk for
that second documentary and you were
kind enough to to come out we rented
this warehouse space in beautiful Los
Angeles it was like this this gritty it
was the appropriate aesthetic for we
were trying to accomplish because we
filmed our talk a few times throughout
the year and like the will the Wilbur in
Boston and it just looked like a
stand-up special it didn't look like how
we wanted it to look there's a good
comedy stand-up special with no comedy
yeah can we get some jokes and so that
can you bet it some jokes in there so we
had rich come out and do the intro for
that and now we've got him here in the
studio for the first time let's go back
to the beginning though before you and I
met because I did your podcast you were
kind enough to invite us
I was in Los Angeles Ryan wasn't so I
was in this tiny little Airbnb and in
West Hollywood and you came out with
your whole setup you look like an
assassin because he was dressed in all
black and he had this like this Pelican
suitcase with him and all of a sudden he
just unfolded it and had a studio right
there what was great about that though
was that the Airbnb that you had was
perfectly minimalist there was almost no
furniture in it and I was like how do
you did you vet this your minimalist
criteria yeah we had the whole team look
into it first there's a minimalist
filter button on Airbnb idea we should
sell that to them Jon edit that out and
we will pitch that to Airbnb later the
minimalist filter no but let's let's go
back to the beginning because because
before rich roll became the rich roll he
was just rich roll and you were not in
flick house rich roll doing before they
were like house rich roll so so you um
well let's let's take it back a decade
or so let's take it back a dozen years
you were approaching age 40 living the
life that you will evolve years ago you
were approaching age 40 just about man
god I hope I look like you when I'm 40
oh I hope I look like you and I'm 30 so
uh let's go back a dozen years where
were you and what were you feeling yeah
so a dozen years ago I was a corporate
attorney and kind of living this
lifestyle premise upon the idea of
chasing the American dream you know my
whole life had been about that had been
about studying hard getting the best
grades getting into the best colleges
got it you know get into a great law
school get the best job you can by the
way the corporate ladder in Cornell Rea
that is true I went to Stanford I went I
was on the swim team at Stanford in the
late 1980s competed on to NC to a
division 1 championship teams as a
benchwarmer I would
somehow got into Cornell law school I
was sort of struggling with alcoholism
during that period of time so I don't
know how I graduated from law school but
somehow they let me through you know got
a job and and got sober at 31 and then
really threw myself into my career you
know III was somebody who had a lot of
promise as a young person squandered a
lot of opportunities because of drugs
and alcohol and then spent a good decade
trying to repair all the wreckage that
I'd created as a result of my drinking
and using career and and very intent
upon like you know getting back to where
I was and so as a result I became a
workaholic
you know just 80 hour weeks in the law
firm the whole bit and it kind of really
moved away from the things that I loved
as a kid which was swimming moving my
body being physically active and healthy
so by the time I was 39 I was successful
in my pursuit of this American Dream I
had a really nice sports car I was in
the partnership track at a prestigious
law firm here in Los Angeles had met my
wife we were building a family and so
from the outside looking in it looked
like I had it made you know I had all
this stuff right and implicit in this
kind of promise of the American Dream
baked into that is this idea that
ultimately this is going to make you
happy right and I wasn't how I love my
wife I you know very happy in my family
situation but really tremendously
unfulfilled professionally and for the
very first time started like questioning
like why am i doing all of this stuff
I'd never really taken a moment to
reflect upon that I was just on this
Habitrail you know for many many years
and so I sort of had this existential
crisis that was percolating up inside of
me and that really butted up against a
health scare that occurred shortly
before my 40th birthday for that decade
and many years prior to that I really
wasn't taking care of myself you know I
had the career as an alcoholic and then
I just segwayed into becoming basically
a junk food addict I had taken a lot of
those addictive tendencies and
transferred them on to food I was
medicating my emotional state with food
and with work and so I'd blown up you
know I gained 50 pounds
lethargic I was depressed about my life
just really unenthusiastic about this
situation that I worked so hard to
create and so what happened was it all
kind of came to a head coming walking up
a simple flight of stairs late one
evening when I had tightness in my chest
I had to take a break up a simple flight
of stairs I was winded out of breath
like buckled over and really terrified
you know heart disease runs in my family
and it was this very crystallized moment
in time in which I finally realized that
dawned upon me like I just can't keep
living this way and that was really the
beginning of re-examining my lifestyle
habits and and reforming my relationship
with food and and reprioritizing how I
was spending my time quite frankly and
and it took many many years to get to a
point where I get to sit here and talk
to you guys but that was really the
beginning of the whole thing so sounds
familiar a little bit yeah so Ryan's
been dealing with some stuff recently
too
we've talked about past podcast you want
to but we can not as a fort for rich
yeah yeah just summarize of rich because
I think our audience has probably heard
it a couple times already so recently I
was well let me just backtrack a second
I was saying it sounds familiar because
it's the living for the American Dream
and and realizing you have nothing yes
that you're at the right table here with
the right people who who have that in
common with uh but what Josh is talking
about specifically is my my blood work I
got back at like the beginning of
February so my cousin passed away
twenty-seven years old from cirrhosis he
was he was a heavy drinker um he had
blood work done in 2014 he was great no
problems and then four years later dies
of cirrhosis if you would if he would
have had a blood test probably would've
saved his life so after seeing this I'm
like man like I don't I know I live a
healthier lifestyle than what he did but
still wanted you know just kind of gave
me that extra motivation to get my blood
checked and when I got it checked my
hemoglobin a1c which is a basically
tells you your average
sugar and your blood for the last 90
days it was that like 7.1 which is I
mean it's pretty much diabetic type 2
diabetes so my doctor called me he's
like dude you gotta tell me about what
you eat and and I was explaining him my
diet and he's like no no no man like how
many donuts do you eat a day and I'm
like dude I haven't had any donuts at
all like in the last six months and long
story short it just turns out that I am
genetically predisposed ition to to
having type 2 diabetes my dad has it my
grandfather has it so I've been doing a
lot of diet modifications over the last
I guess it's going on three months now
maybe four months and I'm just I just
got blood work back two days ago
I am at 5.7 which which is like right
like if I get to five point six nine I
will be considered non no risk for
diabetes right now I'm like a really low
risk but long story short yeah diet has
totally affected my my hemoglobin level
but what I didn't realize is going
through this change in my diet how much
I was covering up with with sugar with
alcohol it's not like I'm drinking a
bottle of Jameson every night but
certainly you know having two or three
drinks four or five drinks on you know
semi regular basis um not all at once
but throughout the day but my point is
is that looking at my lifestyle but yeah
I eat pretty healthy and you know I'm
not like them I'm not the heaviest
drinker I'm not the lightest drinker but
you know I felt like I had these things
kind of in check and cutting them out of
my life I realized how again like how
those things were covering up a lot of
symptoms I was feeling like the biggest
thing I noticed is how angry I get like
I had no idea that I was I always made
fun of other people for getting hangry
you know it was a funny thing but that
like when it happens to me I'm like oh
[ __ ] like this is a real thing it's an
interesting thing when you when you
start to examine the relationship
between food and your emotional state I
remember when I got sober and I would be
in the rooms of recovery and people
would talk about med
getting their emotional stay with food
and I was like what are you talking
about like I had no idea what that meant
and I was completely unaware of the
extent to which I was doing it and it's
not until so what you become we're
saying like I don't know what you're
talking about but the you were doing it
without knowing you were unconscious of
your own actions doing yeah even while I
was trying to really objectively examine
my behavior patterns and how they
related to how it was feeling right so
it's not until you start to strip those
things away and and you know if you
journal it it becomes very clear like
most people will say I pretty good you
know but if you actually write down what
you eat ya know throughout the day like
maybe that's not as moderate as I
thought yeah you know that the denial
starts to peel away and it was
fascinating about that is just the
simple act of journaling I get the app
MyFitnessPal which had a huge data
breach recently so I think now everyone
knows what I eat but at just the simple
act of cataloging it makes you like
question before you put something in
your mouth it'sit's the interesting
thing of being willing to write this
stuff down or type it into an app you
like or sometimes it's like man I'm
gonna eat that but I really don't feel
like feel like typing it into the app so
I'm just not gonna eat it
it changed my relation because once you
become conscious of the thing you start
to adjust it I think about what Ryan was
saying there he had a good diet it's not
like he was eating donuts every day and
ice cream every day but but good is
often the enemy of great and with your
lifestyle you you sort of talked about
how you'd evolved from or evolved or
moved parallel over from alcoholism to a
relationship with with food addiction or
junk food addiction and you had a
overall was supposed to be a good life
but that kept it from being a great life
and in some respects yeah I think you
know at the risk of sounding a little
too esoteric food is a portal to the
soul and I truly believe that the
vibration of what you put in your body
has a tremendous impact on how you see
the world how you interact with people
throughout the day how you interact with
your loved ones how you perform
professionally your energy levels and
and beyond that and
you change that vibration when you raise
that vibration it chains it changes
completely how you move through the
world and I mean that's been my
experience and the experience of so many
people that I've worked with over the
years yeah I can't even believe the the
level of confidence that has risen in me
since changing my diet and it's not
because I actually don't know why it is
I think it's just because I feel
healthier and it's like I it's not like
I walk around like oh man I've lost 20
pounds I'm badass it's like I really
truly feel maybe my head's a little
clearer so I can understand things a
little better I guess and maybe that is
what gives me a little bit more
confidence self-esteem begins with
performing esteem of elack's
and and you know when you're performing
a scheme of all acts on behalf of
yourself
that's going to breed that confidence
right and I think I think that you know
look minimum minimalism and mindfulness
are close allies right and I think just
the the process of becoming more mindful
about the foods that you're putting into
your body breeds that like greater
self-awareness with which also then
buttresses that confidence yeah yeah I
could totally see that so rich you you
went from what was ostensibly a good
life but to you was a mediocre or
actually fairly shitty life because you
weren't fulfilled you weren't happy you
didn't feel contented by by the life
you're in and and you you swung the the
pendulum swung to the other side where I
mean I think so you just what was the
seven years ago you put out your book
finding ultra yeah 2012 okay okay so
five six years ago and then we just had
do we just saw the the re-emergence of
that book you rewrote the whole thing
and put it out again what what and
there's a reason I'm asking this
question but what what motivated you to
like go back and revisit that work
because it is your life's work in a way
well first of all have you ever gone
back and read read something you wrote
eight years ago yeah yeah that I know
rose over comma yeah and it's it's weird
so I an avant 20s and some of the
writing in there some of the most
beautiful writing I've ever created and
I it was from a time in place where I'm
Leigh
I don't know how I wrote that like
somehow I just it manifested it through
my brain into my fingers I don't
remember doing it even but yes I try to
avoid going back and reading stuff that
I wrote even two weeks ago because I'll
just like why did I use a semicolon
instead of a colon there yeah yeah so
there was that but also what I wanted to
do is really bring the story up to date
because so much had transpired in the
year since that book came out I mean
first of all that book came out nobody
really knew who I was and it's been kind
of a slow groundswell of people
discovering it and it continues to sit
sells better every year than the year
before which I'm super proud of but that
in the wake of that book coming out I
faced some crazy challenges and had to
overcome some you know really stiff
obstacles to be able to get to do what I
do today and I I thought that there was
something instructive about that aspect
of the story that went untold in the
first version so I wanted to tell that
and beyond that like there was just a
lot of you know I wanted to go back and
rewrite the parts I didn't like I added
a whole fifty page new chapter that was
it's very instant sort of like a how-to
primer on setting goals achieving goals
how I look at life things that I've
learned you know over this past decade
that I felt like the book was incomplete
without and then just you know
buttressing up the appendices and the
like so it's about a hundred pages
longer now and now it's finally the book
that I always wanted it to be I love
that and and I feel like it's what we
should do with minimalism live a
meaningful life well we did do that in
2015 yeah so our book minam was living
the life came out in 2011 and 2015 we
were rewrote it and sort of sort of
found the principles in it were really
great but it needed some some tweaking
so we did something similar we didn't
had an additional hundred pages to it
because of minimal I guess I feel like
we could a thousand pages well IIIi look
at finding ultra and to me that I
generally hate long subtitles but yours
is like it's a perfect description of
what to expect and it makes you like
sort of want to dive beneath the cover
so so the subtitle is rejecting
middle-age become
the world's fittest men and and
discovering myself so rich really is one
of the world's fittest men you see I
mean you see him while on Instagram in
the mornings and I'm like he lazy
bastard all I'm doing is sitting here
and writing for three hours but he's
he's already wait wait we were arguing
about this this morning Sean
you owe me a coffee by the way why did I
buy your coffee this morning the past
participle of swim is what Ryan uh swam
that's the past tense the past
participle is swum there we go
really giving my coffee Sean swum I
edited the editor Sean you've been
edited anyway you see rich he's like
swimming and then he's running and like
just what I love to do you know well I'm
out doing that I'm thinking I should be
writing you know it's funny how that
works dude if we were on swim teams for
as long as he was we probably would have
some good hat yeah we'd be fish exactly
just like rich and no it's just it's
it's crazy motivating to see to see
someone like like you who is just out
there and really enjoying that because
every morning I make sure I do at least
two things one is right and the other is
exercise some sort of movement for me
I've really bad back I have a fused l5
and s1 and so I I do physical therapy
every morning or I do bodyweight
exercises but it's like nothing compared
to what you do but you're also not the
thing I like about what you do is you're
not prescribing a particular like well I
think everyone needs to go out this
morning and swim 50 laps followed by a
seven mile run and you are simply
encouraging others to to I mean you said
you added a how-to portion here but I
even says I suspect the Hal 2 portion is
based upon what your own recipe is and
then adjust for taste one of the things
that I learned very early in sobriety is
there's nothing more powerful than
sharing your experience so I never tell
people what they should or they
shouldn't do it's not for me to judge
somebody's life experience or to
prescribe you know a lifestyle for them
or to tell them how they should or
should not eat I just share mine
variance so if I go out and run and
train like hey this is what I'm doing
hey this is what I ate this is what I'm
doing and I and I I found that in doing
that it seems to be more powerful it's
sort of like your lighthouse and you
will attract people to you that are you
know interested in what you're doing
rather than saying shaming people or
yeah are like saying you should do this
and don't do that like I mean look
there's a place for that and there's
people that are very good at delivering
messages within that in that spirit
that's just not who I am but most people
who try to deliver that kind of message
that way are really bad at it I think of
a person who's really good at our friend
Julian Smith that you know Julian he
wrote a book called the flinch but he
either way I always describe him is he
is a guy who will pick you up shake the
hell out of you and set you down and
you'll thank him afterward like thanks I
really needed to be I really need to be
shooken like there's a shook and shook
Shawn help me out here now turning into
a grammar podcast we could refile it
there but it but most so I you're a
vegan endurance athlete right I mean if
we were to describe one portion of who
you are right but you're not out the
thing that I love about you is I never
feel like I'm being proselytized to
where you're like you have to do this or
else or you're a bad person or whatever
you're simply illuminating the benefits
for you and that's far more encouraging
we've had I can remember one event we
had this group of 5 vegans who just
waited afterward for us like at the very
end of the hug line that we did and one
of our tour stops you know we have a
good chunk of our audience who are vegan
and most of them are like you they're
like really enjoy the benefits and and
they want to be able to share the fact
that they're plant-based there are other
people who want to shame people into a
particular lifestyle whether that's
veganism or minimalism or you know
playing basketball or whatever your your
you know jungle gym is that you like to
plan and we had this group of people
come afterwards and I remember the the
first lady's while she was I'm really
disappointed in you why okay
you wouldn't be the first person yeah
why are you disappointed in me
oh my you wait you wait on that entire
line and say you're disappoint yeah I'm
just disappointed you guys don't talk
more about veganism and I'm like yeah
I'm like that'd be really weird we
should also talk more about brain
surgery right and she proceeded to spend
her and the group of people she was
perceived to spend next 15 minutes and
they're trying to shame me into changing
my lifestyle and if nothing else if I if
I didn't already have my own informed
opinions that would really turn me off
from a plant-based lifestyle as opposed
to like seeing someone like you or it's
like oh that's that you're aspirational
shaming people is is the opposite of
aspera shaming is shameful yeah it
doesn't really work I mean there's a lot
of well-intentioned people out there
that that you know are trying to put out
a great message but the psychology of it
often is backwards and you know that
kind of messaging is gonna motivate
somebody to go out to the steak house
after you know being you know scolded so
it doesn't it doesn't really work and
I'm not about that at all yeah yeah I
think it's beautiful and instead you you
simply shine a light on what has worked
really well for you in hopes that maybe
some some of the ingredients of your
personal recipe will will work well for
other people and I think by and large
what you're what you're talking about
isn't preaching go without XY and Z it's
go with plant-based diet and that's what
works really well for you it's not like
I'm I'm constantly forsaking all of
these other things like here's what I
get to bring into into my life and I
love the lifestyle and it you know it
restored my vitality and you know I
could speak forever about the benefits
of it but I think that like all things
everything is complicated right it's
about like what works for who when you
know and like I'm not here to say that
what works for me is gonna work for
everybody and you know I think we need
to think more broadly about our
decisions and minimalism is all about
that mindfulness like I said earlier
like what is the impact of the decisions
that we're making the consumer choices
that we're making not just on our own
personal lives but on the world as a
whole as a greater macrocosm I mean you
can be eating a vegan diet but if you're
buying your clothes at H&M like all the
sort of toxic runoff from whatever
factory in Bangladesh is flowing into
some River and killing bazillions of
fish like is that really consistent with
the vegan messaging so you know we have
to step back and and gain greater
perspective on the macro I think yeah
and what does it mean to be intentional
I actually recently brought meat back
into my my life two years ago when I had
some significant health scares and it
was the most terrible egg because I dr.
several doctors recommended after doing
a bunch of blood tests and and for me it
was meat as medicine and I still eat a
probably 90% plant-based diet and and I
remember the first time I had to go back
it was like trying I was literally like
swallowing giant meat pills basically
and I can tell you my health has
improved significantly but that's that's
one one component of it for me it was it
was really about being more intentional
with what I bring into my body
nourishing the body because a meat based
lifestyle a plant-based lifestyle or a
vegan lifestyle isn't necessarily
healthy either there are plenty of you
know you can eat a box of Oreos every
day and say well I'm vegan that why
aren't I healthy well that that's not
what it's really about right it's about
being intentional with with what we put
into our body and how we spend our time
and I think when we lose sight of that I
think you're right that we what we end
up with is some sort of dogma that isn't
that isn't really helpful for anyone
with four questions about food today
should we dive into those we got do
audience questions so on the Twitter
feed there were quite a few questions I
was like well these are very specific I
don't know we picked a few of those
we've got a few voicemails as well so
let's dive into these these callers our
first caller is let me take a look here
Hannah Hannah what do you got to say
Hannah I just have a sort of thank you
for the question specific answer Josh
oh you were I'm a vegan paleo kind of
got it very strict plant-based diet and
you also travel over so wondering how do
you travel on such a miracle diet and
can still maintain a healthy lifestyle
do you see what Josh does out of all
those questions he picks the questions
that are geared towards him that's what
makes it easy for us man no so we we
have traveled a lot and I mean the only
two words that I that I have is a good
answer for Hannah here is Whole Foods
like when we travel that's the one thing
that I can consistently count on or
whatever the Whole Foods equivalent is
you know being Grand Rapids and they
don't have a Whole Foods but they have
something similar so you go you go
somewhere that has but but you you make
it a priority at least for me but rich
you travel a lot what do you do yeah I
mean I've I've traveled extensively and
I've been to all parts of the world I've
been throughout the Middle East and I
you know all kinds of crazy places I've
never had an issue making it work you
know there's a couple strategies that I
employ that make it a little bit easier
I mean first of all when at all possible
I try to book hotel rooms with little
kitchenettes so I can have some control
over the food that I eat and that's not
always possible but when I can do that I
try to do that the second thing is just
like you said find the Whole Foods
wherever you're going like I'll I'll
figure that out before I go and
sometimes I'll even go from the airport
straight to the Whole Foods or the
natural food markets before checking
into the hotel so I get all this food so
even if I don't have a kitchenette I'll
have stuff around me that's healthy so
I'm not in a situation where I'm starved
but I think and then there's a there's a
couple apps like I use an app called
happy cow which shows you where all the
vegan or vegetarian sar wherever you're
traveling all over the world that's
super helpful even if you're paleo I
mean it's basically the healthy
restaurants right so it's a great like
little app you can get on your phone
that's that's been you know crucial for
me you know a lot of people ask me like
well how do you what do you do when you
fly and you're in these airplanes and
you're stuck in this tube you know like
what are you eating I like people tend
to like panic about this kind of stuff
is like look look I mean if I'm find in
New York that's five and a half sick
hours like okay so I'll bring some
snacks like if I just bring a couple
bananas and like some almonds and maybe
some dates like I'm cool like you're not
gonna starve
you know most flights are like three
hours two hours you're gonna be okay
yeah I'm without food yeah so like don't
get so freaked out about this kind of
stuff and I've just learned to relax
about it and and sometimes I don't do
any of that prep I just show up
somewhere and I've done it so many times
that I just like Oh there'll be
something I'll figure it out you
eventually figure it out it's funny man
I was thinking about when so Josh and I
were vegan I was vegan for a year he was
vegan for 11 months he won the bet he
still owes me a dollar but put down the
the yogurt the weird thing is I can't
even eat dairy now I should have won the
bet like like I'm a bad sensitivity
there yeah I feel like coconut yogurt
now and all but back when was this mm
yeah 7080 I was bill was way before the
minimalists do you remember that coconut
yogurt no how did what what inspired
this bet like why do I have this bet so
yeah Josh fat yeah we were fat and we
were getting ready to go on a trip we
had won for being like you know the best
salespeople it was to Maui and I was
talking to Josh like you know a few
months before him I'm like yeah dude
thinking about like you know gonna try
and lose a few pounds before I go to
Maui and he was like yeah I was thinking
about going vegan and I'm like what's
vegan and he's like oh don't worry about
it you could never do it and that's just
all you gotta talk
that's all you need to tell me to do
something to like really I think that
all the time that I Ryan don't worry
yeah but in my house you could never do
and I can tell when he means it and when
he doesn't mean it and I so I looked
into it and I was like I'll call you
back so I looked into it and I'm like
dude I could totally do this
so yeah so thus started my vegan
adventure I was thinking though when so
when I was vegan I could be anywhere
really even if there wasn't a Whole
Foods which in Ohio there I can't think
of one Whole Foods that we had back then
and back in 2007 um I could get by on
subway dude like just going and getting
like lettuce and tomato and onion and
the olive oil and vinegar like those
aren't
meals I would have every single you know
every single meal but in a pinch I mean
I feel like what you're saying is I can
make any I mean I could go to a 7-eleven
and make it work now with my dietary
restrictions it's not as restrict
restrictive as being vegan but it's
still pretty strict and you know if
we're on the roads seriously I can go to
like a 7-eleven and find some almonds I
can find you know some some decent fruit
I can find beef jerky I know you know
any beef jerky but I can find some
things that totally will get me by if I
do have or if I'm in an airport I could
find something that'll get me by for
those long flights or something it's not
it's not as is impossible as people make
it out to be people tend to
overcomplicate it and overthink it we're
just talking about real food I mean
there's grocery stores wherever you're
gonna go go to the produce section and
pick up some nuts and some fruit and
things like that most US cities have
Chipotle so in a pinch like a bowl with
rice and beans and guacamole and hot
sauce like I'm good yeah
Chipotle was my best friend back then
and it's still kind of this today yes
totally but yeah I totally agree yeah
that's that's what we used to do man the
the vegan Chipotle Bowl yeah and and and
so I was on the phone yesterday with
some folks who were trying to open up a
supermarket in our hometown Dayton Ohio
so Dayton Ohio is the second hungriest
city in the country for families with
kids
meaning access to health food the entire
yeah it's I think it's the top five
whose food deserts in the country
West Side doesn't have a single grocery
store we were just back there earlier
this month we were we were filming for
our next documentary and doing some
backstory and like I drove past the last
Kroger that was there out on on
Gettysburg is is silly so I know close
to 2009 so there is an a a so they're
trying to open a food co-op there and
part of it is about education as well
because you can there's food in West
Dayton but but there isn't nutrition in
West a you can go to a liquor store and
buy a bag of chips and a Twinkie and a
candy bar and get some empty calories
but you're not fueling your body you're
certainly not going to feel optimizing
you do that enough
we have the community there the the it's
16% type-2 diabetes it what is it mera
Canaveral I eight percent or something
so it's twice the rate of diabetes is be
part of its because access of food is
not there but what we're trying to do is
we're going to try and help them build
this this grocery store out there and
West state and for those of you listen
this more more details to come that's a
little teaser for you here is you know a
huge problem in this kind of
quote-unquote like wellness movement you
know forget about plant-based vegan just
like being well and being healthy has
become the idea has become that this is
the purview of the well-heeled you're
the well-off and that's a huge problem
that we need to conquer because we're in
this super bizarre situation in which
were overweight and undernourished at
the same time because of places like
Dayton these food deserts where there
isn't access to healthy food and people
that are on food stamps that are on the
SNAP program are going to the corner
bodega and buying chips and you know
crap that's making them sick and
contributing to this diabetes epidemic
and it's a it's a huge problem what's
cool is that I mean what you're doing is
awesome but also seeing this explosion
of urban gardening and kind of these you
know downtrodden areas urban areas that
are now kind of being rejuvenated with
community oriented gardens where where
people are actually growing their own
food on like vacant lots and things like
that and I think that's awesome a lot of
those 10,000 abandoned homes and in
Dayton and some people are taking back a
lot of those those community spaces or
making them community spaces and doing
doing some urban gardening there and I
think part of that has to do with with
education so it's not just about Lego
let's build this grocery store because
if does it just because you have it
there doesn't mean someone's going to
show up and pick carrots over the candy
bar they're used to so it's about it's
about not just having access but having
access to the understanding because I
grew up really poor we were on food
stamps and WIC and you know we get big
tubs of peanut butter and loaves of
white bread and blocks of cheese and
powdered milk
and like that was our a lot of our died
and then we like used some food stamps
to buy fruit roll-ups and which I think
are totally vegan right they're not food
they're vegan the way this desk is vegan
Josh I think yes Josh that coffee cup i
think is probably vegan maybe no animals
were harmed in the making of this coffee
cup but the the important thing is is
not just access but but let's educate
and I think that's what what with
Hannah's question here is like
understanding what your options are and
it's probably not as complex as you
think it is yeah if you're staying in
West Dayton you're probably gonna have
to go down the centre ville and go down
to the the Whole Foods there you have to
drive 10 miles if you if you're in the
city or at least the Kroger on Wayne and
on the east side I mean you're gonna
have to go somewhere where there's a
grocery store but there are grocery
stores and it's ok and if you can get a
hotel with the kitchenette or we often
do Airbnb so we've got the whole set up
there Beck's is the best cook I know so
I'm thankful when I travel with her
because that gives us an additional
option there especially cuz Ella you
know being that she's a four year old
has a picky habits because she's a four
year old right and so there's the other
option that was a third option don't eat
I mean that the BEC travels once a week
or once every other week and on her
travel day she just fast the whole day
and show often fast for 36 hours and you
can do it and you're o.k actually only
too fast every once in a while yeah it's
it's one of the few things that we can
agree on now through science is that
calorie restricted diets help people
live longer now we can argue what
calorie restricted means we can argue
what fasting means we can say
intermittent fasting isn't real fasting
whatever but but the point is yeah if
you're in the out and air for six hours
and a tube doesn't mean you have to eat
just because they come by with the tray
full of of processed carbs and and old
stale meats for you
I'll tell you what Jess Williams our
social media gal used to do I don't know
she still does this but she she was
traveling through the United States she
brings a like a
cooker with her so all she like it's
just she's in a hotel room doesn't have
a kitchen that she can at least plug in
that rice cooker and you can totally you
know throw some veggies and rice and and
whatever else that cheats put it in
there and cook it up won't make me think
about that was Hannah's question I think
she said something about preparing meals
and bringing them with you is that's
something that you have done it all no
okay
never because that seems like really
that seems really crazy there are people
that do that and God bless them and I
think that's another kind of myth or
misconception about the plant-based
lifestyle like oh you must have to spend
all this time preparing all your meals
and set aside one day a week where
you're preparing your meals for the week
and and these recipes must be incredibly
elaborate maybe it's like again I don't
do any yeah I don't do any of that my
wife doesn't do any and we've written
three cookbooks and all of the recipes
are super simple anybody who is a novice
in the kitchen can master them no
problem they're Hardy they stick to your
ribs like they fill you up all of this
sort of thing yes you can go down the
rabbit hole and be that person who's you
know preparing like Tracy Flick an
election who's like super organized and
all that I'm busy I'm doing a million
things I'm traveling all like I don't
have time for that you know and if I can
make it work I'm telling you like people
think on this crazy outlier like I'm
lazy when it comes to this kind of stuff
like I really am and I'm also like a
creature of habit like I really could
like eat rice and beans and guac every
day like it's not a big deal yeah dude
that's what we did in the cabin in the
middle of nowhere it was like rice beans
and that yeah and farts it smell like
firewood and farts but we made it
through yet that's exactly what we did
last thing that I'll say that that has
helped me a lot I used to weigh 80
pounds more than I weigh now realizing
that the food is not entertainment
food is fuel however there's a caveat
here people can always get mad when I
say that food designers it can be no it
shouldn't be entertaining to you so much
as it should be nourishing but you can
also enjoy the food that is nourishing
your body it's still I think it's still
okay to to enjoy it but but I don't want
to think of it as like because weird
would happen you talked about you know
in your book you talk about sort of
being you were this couch potato right
that like within your late 30s like
vigeous eating chips and junk food and
all this other stuff like that's when
food becomes entertainment becomes part
of the entertaining process where it's
just like I'm eating out of boredom with
an entertainment it becomes a drug yeah
food is medicine and food is part of
life it's a beautiful part of life we
should enjoy it but food is not a drug
nor should it be treated like a drug
right and and and when you begin to
become a prisoner of your your cravings
then you've got an issue that you need
to that you need to really look at and I
think there's this idea another mistaken
idea is that if you start eating healthy
that you're just depriving yourself of
joy in your life and what happens is
that those cravings for those foods that
don't serve you subside it's like as
somebody who's a long time in recovery
like the first month of being sober is
tough like you're craving the drug or
the the drink or whatever and it's like
making you crazy and you just can't
imagine going another day without it and
then it dissipates right and now as
somebody who's been sober for many years
like I don't think about drugs and
alcohol really in the same way my
relationship with food has changed so I
don't crave french fries like I used to
and I don't think about cheeseburgers
you know it's like I I look forward to
the healthy foods that not only save me
but nourish me and and fuel me and it
sounds like well that could never happen
to me but I'm telling you like it that's
that's that's what happens your
microbial ecology changes and that has a
big impact on on those cravings and the
quality of those cravings and like I
said like if I could do it I'm telling
you anybody can do it I totally second
that man because my my favorite stuff
before my blood results and found out
that I was you know
heading towards diabetes my favorite
foods were like like ice cream I'd
splurge once or twice a week there are
just you know so many amazing
restaurants in LA I like I we go to a
certain restaurant they put down the big
thing of bread and I you know instantly
I'm just gonna have like one bite or one
piece and then I end up eating like
whole right exactly but what I'll say is
like once I gave up those delicious
sugary
carby treats those fit my favorite
things there were new things that
replaced my favorite thing so now like
if I indulge it's like I'll get a 100
percent dark chocolate bar and never in
my life that I think I would get excited
about a dark chocolate part or even like
a handful of blueberries never thought I
would get excited about a handful of
blueberries but now man like I it is it
is my that is my new favorite so I mean
just to your point of yes your whole
your whole tastes change your cravings
change you just kind of got to get
through that that month or two month
period of of getting all that crap out
of your body I know for the first two
months man I was mad like I was really
angry yeah that I had to say no to to
bread I just say no to ice cream and
then a couple that yeah absolutely
absolutely yeah and you could be walking
around pissed off like why can't I spend
my money on all these things that other
people like I'm a minimalist now and I'm
angry because I can't now you probably
don't think about it right I don't know
yeah this is like maybe I'm different
than other people in this regard but I'm
not a big fan of a lot of people are
like we'll have a cheat day like eat
really well six days a week and then
have your cheat day like that just would
not work for me because if you told me I
could eat in-n-out burger one day a week
I would spend the other six days just
thinking about you know and then that
one day would turn into two days and
then and then I'd just be eating it all
the time like I need to like divorce
myself from that food until I don't
crave it anymore and then you're no
longer imprisoned by it I love how you
said I'm free from it because like I'm
going I'm going to see Elton John this
weekend he's playing in Las Vegas Mariah
and I are going with our friends and
they were over a couple nights ago and
they're talking about all this amazing
desserts and and and all this food that
they get when they're in Vegas and every
time they would say something they would
be like oh you have a Ryan you probably
can't eat that a Mariah
you've got the dietary sure because you
can't probably eat that
no no they were they were actually
supporting oh I got you yeah um but but
uh long story short they what they were
saying that the foods that they were
presenting there was nothing to me that
I was like oh damn I'm gonna miss out on
that like I truly am not jealous we're
two months ago I would have been pissed
off I don't know like [ __ ] I gotta go to
Vegas and avoid all that and now it is
it's like oh great like I'm like I can
be happy for them if they're going to
enjoy food
I will which is really weird I really
enjoy watching people eat all the [ __ ]
that I used to like but I don't want to
eat it
so you had to have the willingness the
wherewithal to be uncomfortable for a
couple weeks and like ride it out while
you were angry to get to the other side
and I think that gets missed in this
conversation which is yeah maybe it's
gonna suck for a little bit you know but
when you're working towards betterment
like you have to go through like a
little bit of discomfort to get to that
place and most people don't want to do
that but the truth is like if you can
you know buck up and and just you know
walk through that discomfort and know
like there is light on the other side of
that that's that's really the path
forward to creating something
sustainable yeah well and I'd love to
send you a copy of Rich's new book it's
a he and his wife Julie wrote a book
it's a third your it's at your third
recipe book yeah well my we wrote the
plant power way came out a couple years
ago that my wife wrote a plant-based
cheese book called this nut so she she's
the sole author on that one and I'm
gonna jointly wrote this new one so this
is a plate oh yeah the plant power way
Italia we just got a copy of it in the
mail and Bex open it up she was like oh
my god I can't wait to dive into this I
was just looking at it I'm like yeah it
looks there's a lot of good recipes in
there yeah so we'll send you a handle
we'll send you a copy of that
I'll have Shawn reach out to you and
we'll send you a copy all right our next
question is from Kimberly I want to ask
you guys opinion on buying organic
vegetable enthuse and also grass-fed
meat in how people on a budget
can the for adult food because they are
usually more expensive than regular food
all right so so rich buying healthy
foods is too expensive I'm sure you've
heard that before
well you mentioned it just the previous
question how we have this thing or
whenever we were talking before about
how eating healthy is like this this
it's only for the well-off I think is
what you said right so how do I answer
this best I mean the first thing I would
say just don't you know to directly
answer her question Organic is better
you know I'm I think it's important if
you have the money to invest in organic
now there are certain foods where it's
more important to buy organic rather
than conventionally grown there's a list
called the Dirty Dozen you can find it
on the environmental working groups
website and gets ewg org also like that
in the show know and and and I would
urge everybody if you can make it work
within your budget to to make that you
know make that investment in yourself
you're gonna pay for it at some time in
your life so pay for it now rather than
in your healthcare bills later I did a
podcast recently with this amazing
doctor Zack Bush who spoke at length
about the ills of conventional farming
and the pesticide residue that ends up
in our food and the link between all of
this and the incidence of chronic
illness later in life and so I do think
it is important that being said I am
sympathetic to those who are on a budget
and and and can't and simply can't
afford organic so if you can't buy
organic that's not an excuse to not buy
fresh produce that's always better than
not eating produce or high-fiber plant
foods so please you know don't be
confused about that but if you can I
really think organic is worth it yeah I
I totally agree have heard the same
thing the list is very interesting to me
because there are some things on there I
don't know if I've seen the same exact
list but there are some things on that
list that truly don't eat like oranges
like
you really don't have to worry about
buying oranges organic because I said is
that true correct me if I'm wrong yeah
I'm trying to remember the list and the
the specific items elude me right now I
know strawberries are super important to
buy organic there are some that are
better than others and I think you know
where people get confused is they think
well if I just wash it off it's fine but
you know glyphosate the active
ingredient and Monsanto's Roundup these
things they're in the soil and they get
absorbed into the roots so it becomes
integral in the food itself yeah right
it's gonna be there no matter what I I
agree with you when I think of myself
and if I'm like well I can't afford to
buy something in this case it's like I
can't afford not to treat myself myself
in a healthful way right and so yeah
you're gonna end up paying for it later
but but you're gonna pay for in a bunch
of other ways that aren't just the
medical bills or whatever else it's
paying for it in the way that you feel
you don't have the optimized life and so
the way that I look at this is like
what's your budget and Kimberly do you
have a budget if you make $2,000 a month
how much of that is allocated to your
groceries and the question then is if
you have you know $400 allocated to your
groceries and if organic gonna cost you
an additional 50 bucks a month where can
that $50 come from for me income from
one or two places I can either take it
from somewhere else in my budget and
it's more important to me to to eat
healthfully than it is to have cable TV
or something like that or I can find a
way to make an additional $50 a month
that might mean driving uber one night a
month or something like that so like I
can afford to buy the the the fuel for
my body because otherwise I'm gonna put
junk in there and of course I put junk
in my body all I'm gonna get is junk out
yeah and I think that's absolutely right
and you know maybe look at how much
money are you spending going out to
lunch you're going out to dinner or
restaurants other areas where you're
spending money on food and be really
honest with yourself about that also the
organic market is is shifting and
changing you know places like Costco and
Walmart are stocking more and more
organic foods yeah and the rice and
their booze yeah
they're being it they're able to deliver
it at a more affordable price point I
don't know if there's a farmers market
in your region but sometimes you can cut
deals with the local it's always better
to buy local anyway and if you can like
develop a relationship with with the
farmers at your local farmers market you
can get you can get special deals there
this weekend the farmers market and and
like it's amazing the act that and you
still have to get the conventional
versus versus organic you'll find the
conventional stuff there too but it's
just like going to the grocery store but
but you can actually it's much easier to
barter with someone who is there the
decision maker I can't go to the cashier
at Aldi and say hey can you give me
fifteen percent off the blueberries
they're looking like you're crazy yeah I
noticed like even sticker price on stuff
was a little bit cheaper at the farmers
market that we went to yeah like just
for avocados and strawberries and stuff
like that so when it comes to budgeting
we did a whole podcast episode on
getting your budget together so Kimberly
I would encourage you to take a deep
dive in your budget Sean we put a link
to that that podcast episode in the show
notes the the budgeting episode because
there's really there's nothing more
important than your health if you don't
have your health that then everything
else is going to suffer
so let's let's find a way to put that
first so if you're asking this question
I say Kimberly Bravo to you for asking
this question now the question you have
to ask yourself is how can I make this
happen how can I make it happen so I'm
buying what is actually gonna fuel my
body as opposed to get in the way of my
life success yeah and if Kimberly yeah
but just to echo what Josh said if
you're feeling like yeah there's no way
you can afford it
definitely definitely listen to that
budget podcast because there are some
really good tips on there and just
figuring out how you can kind of make
different things work my favorite the
first thing I think of with it when with
that podcast is the likes once needs
list yeah yeah we another way to
position that would just be essentials
non essentials and junk
quite often we're buying a lot of junk
for our households and not realizing
like we're forsaking the essentials as
as a result
Kimberly I'd love this in your copy of
Rich's book finding ultra the the new
edition in the gist
a melt so Shawn if you could reach out
to Kimberly and get her a copy of the
book I would I'd appreciate that I think
you'll find a lot of value on it all
right let's uh oh
before we move on we'd love to hear what
you all have to say so if you have a
comment or tip about food including
advice for any of our callers today then
leave us a voicemail for zero six two
one nine seven eight three nine you can
also email a voice memo right from your
phone to podcast at the minimalists comm
we will air our favorite comments and
tips at the end of each episodes my
favorite part of the show because we get
to steal your advice and reappropriation
what time is it you know what time it is
it's time for our lightning round where
we answer questions from social media do
you remember how this worked last time
well we think we did like free you guys
are second yeah super pro well we are on
we try to be we have a piece of paper
printed out that's the only thing that
makes the professional here we're on
Twitter Facebook and Instagram at the
minimalists during the lightning round
so Ryan and I both do our best to each
answer every question which is the short
shareable less than 140 character
response we also put the text to these
minimal Maxim's in the show notes so you
can copy and share our pithy answers on
social media if you'd like and now
Jessica puts all of our quotes in one
place we have hundreds or maybe even
over a thousand of our own quotes now
over at minimal Maxim's com so rich the
way that this will work for you is we
come up with a tweetable answer but
usually we Mandar on a bit anyway so
eventually we'll come up with something
pithy for you as well but we'll ask some
questions here from social media you
want to start with Ashley's question
Ryan I will our first letting your own
question is from Ashley she writes in
how do you separate what is trendy from
what is actually beneficial for you well
my pit the answer and then all unpack it
a little bit is that which is real often
isn't trendy and that which is trendy
often isn't real and I mean you know
what it may it's the the real foods
it may be trendy at some point in time
to be instagramming something beautiful
or whatever but like we've been eating
real foods well before we had
agriculture even you know
seventy thousand years ago we were
eating real foods right and and so it I
think what what Ashley is asking here is
like they're often these these fad diets
and we see these very prescriptive sort
of diet books or recipe recipe plans or
whatever how do you get around that rich
how do you get around being trendy and
instead focusing on what is real I think
you hit it on the head
I mean eat real food close to its
natural state you know would be a good
one or Michael Pollan's famous quote
which is like eat eat real food mostly
plants not too much yeah you know it's
like that's not that's not going out of
style that's not a trend and yeah
there's trends come and go and we see
you know these sort of very emotionally
heated arguments on line about which
diet is best etc but ultimately you know
anybody who's well-intentioned about
their diet is going to agree on 90% of
these items and that 90 percent can be
boiled down to a pithy tweet which is
just eat real food yeah my partner
Rebecca she often talks about like that
90 percent that we can all agree agree
on and then you play around on what the
edges what's appropriate for you right
and so some people we say well this
particular diet is appropriate for me a
paleo diet or a keto diet or the Atkins
diet or a vegan diet a vegetarian diet
you play around with the edges but the
the healthy diet is gonna be 80 90
percent the same on all of those if you
put all those on a thin diagram
you're probably and if you're doing them
in in a healthful way you're going to
notice that like they are almost all the
same in the center and you're just
playing with what the the details are on
the edges and also pay attention to
yourself and what works for you
forget about trends like be your own
arbiter of what is successful for you
like journal it how do you feel today
what did you eat today and tweak
accordingly until you find the recipe
that is best suited for your lifestyle
in your disposition yeah absolutely
that's a good lead-in to my my tweetable
answer trendy and beneficial aren't
always opposites the question asked is
how is trendy or what is trendy how is
it going to serve your life so to your
point something can be trendy and it
actually might be beneficial to you but
that's something that the person is
going to have to decide for themselves I
mean I wish that Josh and I and and and
rich could be like oh you know what we
the three of us know what the perfect
diet is for every single person on this
on the planet we figured it out guys for
that this room until we got it but the
truth is I mean even though we're all
humans and like you know by and large
what we're the same when it comes to
nutrition we do all operate a little bit
differently and and we have to figure
that out for ourselves yeah we have
different microbiomes we have been
plagued with different health issues and
and so what is appropriate for me may
not be a program for you and and also we
rich can eat 40,000 calories a day
because he just swims it off every
morning I bet you you're at 5,000
calories a day some like that right
you'd be surprised I actually I probably
don't eat that much more than then
either of you guys I just over the years
I become I become a ritual kick right
know my caloric intake I mean it's gonna
be a little higher than the average
person but it's not like crazy it's not
like the Michael Phelps crazy diet I've
become just very adapted to the training
that I do so it's it's just not as
taxing anymore as it once was
yeah you become more efficient okay okay
I was I was a it was visiting dr. Greene
yesterday yeah and I was he was telling
me about exercise routines and how
basically your your body is like the
laziest mechanism for burning calories
like it will find the laziest way to
burn the calories and what we what
brought that up is I was talking about
my workout and how you know I pretty
much except the exercise is a little bit
from week to week but you know I don't
see the results that I really want and
he was explaining to me how I mean you
know how it is if you do the same exact
routine yeah then like your body gets
used to it you become more efficient at
it and you're you're able to burn
calories in an efficient way and do what
you need to do
but uh but yeah I'm gonna change it over
the next few weeks I gotta mix it up man
I'm Dean
speaking of mixing it up with our next
question Ryan all right man our next
lightning round question is from Daniel
what are your thoughts on the
relationship between good nutrition and
mental health it seems it's often not
discussed yeah so I my father was with
schizophrenic I mean like legitimately
he had elaborate relationships with
people who who didn't exist in the real
world and it made for a really rough
initial childhood yeah I didn't know him
much after age three or four because
like we had to move away he got really
abusive and crazy and I to what extent
that was exacerbated by his diet I don't
know but he was also clinically obese
and did one calls the other and maybe
maybe not I don't know but I know it
certainly didn't help that he had a
terrible diet right and so are we
talking about mental health I mean it
seems like we're we're talking more
about it now than then we have in the
past there there was a stigma for a very
long time
and and so I'm glad that we're talking
about it sad the context we're talking
about it now is like well there are all
these mass shootings and the one
commonality between all the mass
shootings
it's besides guns is mental health
almost all of these people are on some
sort of psychiatric medicine or have
been diagnosed and we we have a huge
mental health crisis and I think part of
it is also a crisis of of meaning and so
we've we've turned to a lot of different
pacifiers and we're living unhealthful
II and part of that moment here was my
short answer that I wrote down our
brains and bodies are not standing in
separate rooms and I think sometimes we
often think that right they especially
in academia you'll see people who are
very unhealthy but we're really smart
and it's like it seems so incongruous
with me like because we think of our
mind as being the separate thing from
our body but our body fuels our mind and
vice versa
right
yeah I mean that was exactly the point
that I was gonna make you know first of
all just to preface it you know mental
illness is is is certainly real and it's
a spectrum and it comes in many
different forms and and diet is not
necessarily the antidote
you know the cure to many you know many
of the conditions that that that are
plaguing people that being said this
idea this dualistic notion that there is
mental health and physical health or
there is your brain and there is your
body and that these things are separate
entities is insane it's all one
integrated mechanism and when you're
when you're thinking about physical
health that that also you know you're
talking about brain health as well you
know I had a health of your brain yeah
of course these things are not the are
they're interdependent they're
interrelated and and they I think the
more that we can think about it as a
symbiotic whole the better off we are
and the truth is when you are eating a
healthier diet that's going to be better
for your brain health and your mental
health you know your your energy levels
that affects your your mental
disposition the extent to which you're
depressed or not depressed etcetera
things like this can all be modulated to
some extent based upon your lifestyle
choices and your diet I just I just had
these doctors on my podcast a while back
this husband and wife team the sure's
A's and they've been treating
Alzheimer's patients with diet and
lifestyle and getting incredible results
and this is a disease that you know look
it's an epidemic and Western medicine
has been really striking out and trying
to find a way to prevent and reverse
this and it was amazing to hear the
impact that these doctors and and other
people out in the world are having by
really going back to this idea of
lifestyle and diet and I think it just
speaks to you know the power of the
choices that we're making with respect
to the foods that we're eating and how
we're moving our bodies etc can have on
our
mental state yeah the movie in your body
part is really important too because I
lived a very sedentary lifestyle to the
point where I had turned off a lot of
muscles in my body because I was I was
seated you know eight to 12 hours a day
most days in my car alive I manage a
bunch of retail stores so I was just
like and go from place to place to play
so I'd sit down in meetings all day and
I didn't get up and move I didn't really
exercise and I got to a point where I
think part of the despair that I felt
was because I wasn't moving the way and
now we're starting to see more more
comprehensive studies that show that in
many cases movement is as effective if
not more effective in some patients than
some of these antidepressants right and
the clinical depression is a real thing
but just because you're feeling down or
feeling sad feeling a little bit of
despair doesn't mean that unit are
necessarily clinically depressed maybe
you've just created a shitty life for
yourself like I did one that looked
great like had this there's really good
veneer but it was rotting underneath
right and and so maybe it's not just the
the mental health side of things it's
just this mental fog it's a mental
despair that we're feeling that we can
we can cure a lot of that we can cure
ourselves with what we put into our body
and then how we move our bodies as well
there's a guy called Johann Hari who
recently wrote a pretty amazing book the
name escapes me right now but a little
bit about depression yeah and and how
you know look certain people need to be
medicated but we're just so quick to
prescribe and I think that there is
wisdom in really evaluating lifestyle
habits and and the extent to which your
life is filled with purpose and meaning
and the impact of that on your overall
mental disposition yeah but a pill is so
much easier easier than exercising it's
easier than eating right and you know
it's easier than budgeting for life you
don't have to you don't have to look in
the mirror honestly either yeah yeah I
know I totally read you guys are saying
my short answer is this food addiction
can be as hard to overcome as
addiction like when I think about when I
was coming off of my drugs I was like
opiates were like pain pills were like
my thing and coming off of that brutal
man I mean like yeah like a month of not
being able to sleep not to sleep well
like the first week it was like hardly
any sleep and then the last three weeks
it was you know maybe three or four
hours and night if I could get that in
but long story short it getting getting
off of sugar getting off of of those
really nice fast burning carbs that I'm
not allowed to eat anymore
again like there was a month or two
where I was just like angry or like I
had to really I don't wanna say suppress
the anger but I really had to like tell
myself like Ryan take some deep breaths
it's okay you don't have to let out this
mad feeling that you have right now but
it was at least two months of really
kind of on this on this roller coaster
but but just speaking to how food
actually
absolutely does affect your mental
health coming off of it will affect your
mental health a little bit too maybe
yeah I think if the thing I wrote down
here is if you fuel your body you fool
you fool your brain and and if you're
abusing your body you're also abusing
your brain because it's it's all there
it's all tied up you can't be treating
your body like crap and think that it's
not going to affect every part of your
body it is and your brain is using a lot
of calories throughout the day and if
you're just putting in a bunch of
garbage calories then guess what you're
gonna feel like garbage
alright we have one more question here
this question is from Jamie Jamie says
how can I make being a vegan more
economical some of the stuff you need to
do it right can be expensive also
running / outdoor gear can be pricey so
it's expensive to run any tips on that -
so so before we dive into that if you
want to hear our answers to that
question you can listen to our
PostScript episode this week each week
we publish our PostScript episode over
at the minimalists private podcast which
shows up as a separate feed in the same
exact podcast app you're using right now
to listen to this episode the middle is
private podcast is just for our patreon
supporters
that's the supporters of this podcast
and it's that's why it's private so if
you want to support our show and keep
this podcast 100% advertisement free
then head on over to the minimalists
comm slash support the middle most
private podcasts feed includes our
weekly PostScript episodes but also
includes our monthly ask the minimalists
anything episodes were actually
recording one of those letters today
unreleased recordings of all of our live
events there on that feed and our entire
back catalog of past private podcast
episodes as a supporter you also receive
access to our monthly video live streams
as well as first access to tickets to
all of our live events before those
tickets are available to the general
public you can find all the details and
all the good stuff over at the
minimalists comm slash support and
here's a quick snippet from this week's
PostScript episode I have so much to say
about this question because it gets
right to the heart of so many myths and
misconceptions about eating plant-based
and also the fitness lifestyle so first
of all with respect to quote unquote
like trying to do plant-based right
there's this idea that to do it right
you have to go to Whole Foods and buy
all these exotic superfoods like
spirulina and hemp seeds and chia seeds
and all the like because that's what
ends up on Instagram because that's
what's sexy that's what people like to
talk about because it's new but the
truth is eating plant-based this is
popper food this is not fancy I made a
video about this on YouTube it's the
most video most watched video I've ever
made on my You Tube channel
it sort of parodies this whole thing
it's called vegan on $25.00 and I go to
a bunch of different markets and I see
what I can get for 25 bucks and I start
with like the like erawan the fanciest
and I'd literally buy like two blueprint
juices they're like you know like and
that's it that's all I can get for 25
bucks it's like and because that's like
who if you want to be like in wellness
you have to get your your fresh-pressed
you know whatever and it's super
expensive yeah it can be expensive if
that's
road that you're traveling to air one
charge you $25 admission and I go I go
to like five markets and I end up at
this like Indian market like deep in the
valley like you know this weird like
place and I literally walk out of there
with this like 25 pound bag of rice and
then this other giant you know like 10
pound bag of black beans like dried
beans or whatever and I was still like
under 25 bucks it's like the truth is
stick to the basic items like if you can
buy you can buy a month's worth of rice
for like 10 bucks right and that can
provide the base for so many dishes that
you're gonna make you can buy beans for
close to nothing you can make vegan
chilies with that you can make all
different kinds of stuff with these
basic items and then when you go to the
grocery store look if you can't afford
organic because that's too expensive and
by conventional when you can buy organic
but stick to the edges at the grocery
store don't avoid all those middle
aisles where all that processed crap is
and a lot of that stuff's expensive too
right so just get your fresh produce
your vegetables your fruits your nuts
your seeds your whole grains and I think
you'll be surprised that it's much more
affordable than you think a lot of these
animal products and dairy products
that's where the money is going so there
are ways to do it in a very
cost-effective way
[Music]
all right now it's time for our
added-value portion of the shows so we
reach to talk about something that has
added value to our lives recently so I'm
going to talk about a few things here
because we're talking about food today
and I was thinking like what can be what
could be food adjacent and we've already
talked about Rich's new books and
whether it's finding Ultra or the plant
power Wei Italia and so I would
encourage folks if you're interested in
those you can pick those up if you're
looking for additional recipes as well
my my partner Rebecca runs a great blog
called minimal wellness.com I was eating
her Buffalo cauliflower this weekend and
then eating the leftovers and eating
more leftovers ever had Buffalo
cauliflower I didn't enjoy like it is it
is so good yeah yeah it was it was great
so you can find that recipe actually she
just put it up on on her website over at
minimal wellness comm and also while we
were she was cooking this weekend we
were sort of hanging out in the kitchen
together we're listening to this new EP
from aquilo I know they're one of my 10
favorite albums of last year but they
just put on a new EP it's almost like
atmospheric music it's like the perfect
cooking music it's its atmospheric it's
slow but it's also building we just
turned on the speakers and had it going
on repeat it's a five song EP and it's
just called to like the Roman numeral
two we'll put a link to that and
actually you know what they have a great
song called thin and there's a perfect
line in there about about minimalism
about what what's what's the purpose of
having all these things if it's just
going to make you thin and thin as in
like a thin life as in not full and and
so it to me it was like this perfect
metaphor but it was it was just like
great music to spend the weekend sort of
hanging out with backs and she was
cooking some amazing stuff and also I'm
gonna not necessarily recommend but just
tell you about something I've been
trying recently its added value to my
life the last few days you know how if
you get a phone call you say hey I'm
gonna step outside let me take this
really quickly right like oh crap I'm
getting a phone call I'm gonna step
outside and let me take this really
quickly we were at brunch the other day
because of us yes that's what you do in
LA on
sundae's you have brunch yes it was at
9:00 a.m. I don't know if that was like
the right brunch time but well yeah but
the key in LA to do brunch is before
10:00 a.m.
otherwise you have to wait an hour and a
half line anywhere but you know how you
take a phone call and you're like hey
let me let me step outside and take this
I've been doing this with text messages
oh my god it's like it makes me so much
more intentional about I say hey let me
step out and take this text message
really quick because it's just a way for
me to say pardon me I'm acknowledging
the fact that I'm interrupting us right
now
and so it makes me want to do it less
frequently but sometimes there is really
a time where I need to step out I really
need to send this text message I really
need to do this but I'm not going to
pull this barrier out in front of us and
say hold on I'm gonna send this text
message and I'm just holding it and
placing this barrier up and it makes me
more deliberate and so I'm working on an
essay about it right now but if for
those of you want to try it out if you
just send me a tweet on on Twitter let
me know how it's going for you it's been
something that has changed my
relationship with the phone being on me
saying I have to step out of this room
or away from this table so even I do
this at home pardon me I'm gonna go take
this text message and it's totally it's
just reframed it for me so I'd encourage
you all to maybe give that a shot see
what it does for you and one more thing
that has added value to my life because
I've listened to quite frequently is
rich rolls podcast it's called the rich
roll podcast very appropriate named and
everything we're talking about with rich
roll today you can find over at rich
roll comm his podcast his books finding
ultra all of the recipe books his blog
and and all everything social is all
linked up there you can find him on on
Instagram and let him inspire you there
as well Ryan what has been adding value
to your life recently man I was trying
to think of something food adjacent and
well what I'll say is if you're ever in
the LA area or if you live in LA there's
a place called creation starts with a
que have you heard of this yes oh yeah
it's so so well there are so many places
in LA man at first I didn't even realize
it was a chain but they I think it's
just it's just LA
is that correct that I don't know okay
there's one on a bikini in Venice - okay
okay so so maybe they've expanded a
little bit but the reason why they
haven't expanded to you know much
further than LA County is because they
are so particular with their the
ingredients that they source so they are
going out of their way to get local
ingredients from local farmers and and
they're they're very intentional with
that to open one up in Chicago they
would lose a lot of that quality so I
just see I really appreciate the chain
it is it is uh it's one of Mariah and
i's favorite places to eat and then I'm
gonna recommend an album dude it's funny
I'm coming across all these old these
albums that came out last year that I'm
just now finding out about cuz like I'll
put on like a like I'll put on a quillo
radio on on iTunes or something they're
like 2017 albums you're like why is this
new to me like why is this so new but if
it's new to me it might be new to
someone else but there's a you wouldn't
like them Josh but that's alright guys
you heard of the Beatles yeah this is
1965 album I really like no it's a band
called Deer Tick and they had an album
out last year called Deer Tick volume 1
it's very it's like a mix between like
singer-songwriter type style but also
like doctor dog if you know who that is
yeah so it's like it's it's a good mix
between like that John I think doctor
dog we third they would be considered
like independent singer-songwriter folks
but they have like their own style it's
kind of like singer-songwriters genre
mixed with that doctor dog style anyway
it's really good check it out alright
well let's move on to right here right
now so we talked about what's going on
in the lives of the minimalist well this
is coming out on the 1st of May it's a
brand new month which means a brand new
30-day minimalism game for those of you
who are uninformed about the minimalism
game it's like one of the most popular
things I had this lady walk up to me
where I was at a Noah Gunderson concert
down in Orange County and she goes hey
you you're one of the middle of those
guys right I'm like uh-huh
she goes I have you heard of the 30-day
minimalism game
I'm like yeah I made it up and she's
like I know I don't know why I said that
that's great but you know it's it's one
of the things like decluttering is I
think it's kind of boring when we talk
about decluttering like yeah you don't
think if I want to spend my weekend just
cleaning out the closet right like it's
but so we found a way to make it a
little more fun so it's by injecting
some friendly competition into it so the
way the 30 day minimalism game works is
you find a friend a family member a
co-worker arch nemesis archenemy what's
the plural of arch nemesis yeah your
enemies anyway you find some people you
want to partner up with the beginning of
the month and each agree to get rid of
some stuff it starts off really easy to
get that momentum you need the average
American household has 300 thousand
items in it most people don't know where
the hell to start in their own house and
so you can just start somewhere the
first day of the month you each say I'm
gonna get rid of one item each second
day of the month two items third day the
month three items fourth day four items
so forth and so on so it starts off
really easy get you that momentum you
need but by the middle of the month
you're like oh my god how am I gonna
keep going it's day 15 I have to get rid
of 15 items and tomorrow I have to get
rid of 16 items now whoever goes the
longest wins so you can bet whatever you
want you can bet a dollar like Ryan and
I would or or tens of thousands of
dollars if you want or just a meal or
just bragging rights whoever goes the
longest wins if you both make it end of
the month you've both won because you've
you've gotten rid of about 500 items and
it's a really good start we've had
communities of people who keep going on
day 30 to day 35 or they'll just start
over beginning in the next month they
won all over again
you can follow details of that at the
minimalists comm slash game we'll also
put a link to that in the show notes we
also have a video version of this
podcast coming soon we're in our new
studio space here rich is one of our
first guests and thank you we it's
supported by our patreon supporters so
thank you so much the the folks who
support us on patreon you allow us to
have this beautiful space and where as
soon as we have enough supporters we're
gonna have a video version of the
podcast set up as well we're gonna hire
a full time filmmaker to help us out
with that you can subscribe to that over
at youtube.com slash the minimalist
we're gonna have TK Coleman on
Podcast next week yeah you know
education and the difference between
education and schooling and we're also
going to talk about careers so I look
forward to having that discussion with
TK Coleman next week I'm also doing a
now that we're finally settled here in
Los Angeles and I got to say I love
living in Los Angeles it's it's great
yes awesome it's it's the great people
like I get to spend time like it before
like living in Missoula like it's
beautiful but like I didn't have my my
tribe there and so I I had Ryan and
Shawn I had to I had to move my tribe
they're basically like hey people from
Ohio you want to come with me but here
like I'm able to like spend time with
people I care about the weather is
amazing I've found my pockets of people
I like it's a bad rap I think sometimes
because of the people and what I
realized it's like well wait a minute
they're like 20 million people here and
in Southern California if you can't find
your tribe that's not the people of the
people here it's the fault of me for not
being able to find my own tribe and yeah
it took a little while for me to to get
engrained in the right pockets but it is
so good living here now I just I really
enjoy it but I'm gonna do a house tour
of Beck's and mine Ella's house on may
11th at 9 a.m. Pacific time over on our
Instagram live feed so we're at the
minimalists on Instagram and it's only
gonna be up for 24 hours because that's
how Instagram live work so if you want
to check that out you don't even have to
follow us on Instagram I don't think you
can just go over there and find it or if
you do want to follow us and then
quickly unfollow us that's totally fine
with me too
but yeah it's may 11 9:00 a.m. Pacific
time we'll do a live tour I'll answer
some of your questions as well I already
alluded this but Ryan and I as well as
Matthew Vella and our crew here podcast
Sean as well are working on the new
documentary it's called the minimalists
les is now and we're actually headed out
to Joshua Tree next week in the film
some stuff with that some interviews and
some b-roll we were just in Dayton Ohio
we got in this beautiful abandoned mall
it's it's it's it looked amazing it will
see incredible it failed because they
turned it into a mall wasn't actually a
mall
unis gathering space built in 1904 and
then they try to revitalize it I put
that in Volkl quotes here and they
turned into a mall in the late 70s early
80s and it's this most beautiful space
and they're gonna repurpose it now and
turn it into something great as opposed
to shopping it's gonna be turned into
mixed-use housing and co-working space
and retail I'm really optimistic for
that we wanted to get in there it was
the perfect metaphor riot Ryan said this
when we were filming it was a perfect
metaphor for consumerism like when you
consume too much this is what happens
everything crumbles and so we went back
we did some filming there and Dayton
went back to my childhood home which is
boarded up now and hopefully we'll have
that edited the summer and who knows
maybe by the end of the year we even
have that out in front of the rest of
the world yeah I'm really looking
forward to that
also some a bunch of new writings now
that we're done touring I've been
writing a whole lot up on our website
just go to the minimalistic comm you
could put your email address at the top
there we'll send you any new essays that
are published also any of the the show
notes that we always mention those will
go right to your email inbox as well
we'll never send you spam because you
know that stuff's gross I think it's all
I have right now Ryan do you have
anything else yeah man I've got these
voicemail comments and tips from our
listeners this is Cecilia Duffy from
geneva ohio i have some tips for helping
to minimize your food preparation to
keep things healthy yet not taking time
daily to cook this opens up time to
pursue those things that you value i'm
recently widowed and my daughter is away
at college so it is only me to cook for
most of the time due to my life change
and challenges I am working longer hours
to support myself and daughter as a
chiropractor a core value of mine is to
eat healthy and organic but I don't want
to take the time to cook on a daily
basis like I did when I worked part time
and was feeding my family of three on
Sunday mornings I put on the newest
podcast of the minimalist and head to
the kitchen to cook for the week it
takes me less than two hours to cook for
the week and clean up the kitchen this
will work for those who don't mind
eating the same thing for a week at a
time
for breakfast I cook up turkey sausage
and have fresh fruit available other
breakfast
include my homemade granola with almond
milk and nuts for lunch this is where I
get my daily greens I use a very large
Tupperware container and place washed
lettuces radishes shredded carrots cukes
olives etc all ready to go
I chop this salad with prepared proteins
I cook up lean protein like chicken
turkey and fish enough to last for all
lunches and dinners for the week I buy
enough to allow 4 ounces per serving
I figure out how many times I plan to
eat out that week and adjust accordingly
for dinner I make ahead tons of roasted
steamed or sauteed vegetables I will
make one starch a week to eat with
dinner rotating between rice quinoa
pasta or sweet potatoes other times I
will make a large pot of soup or stew
that incorporates all the food types a
protein starch and lots of veggies for
snacks I make a homemade trail mix with
raw nuts raisins dried cherries and
apples celery with almond butter and
raisins is another favorite nut or
granola bars also work for snacks all
foods are placed in separate containers
in the refrigerator I use a stainless
steel container with a bpa-free lid
called lunch bot I buy only what I need
for the week this keeps costs down and I
don't have a lot of unused food sitting
in a pantry when my daughter is home
from school I just increase the amounts
that I cook to accommodate feeding her
as well um hi my name is Emily and I
wanted to share a minimalist parenting
tip I was listening to the parenting
episode and some was asking about
whether or not to save baby things for a
potential future child and in it at
first it seems like a really good ideal
idea or even frugal and that's what I
thought when I have my daughter but then
I realized that my next child could very
well be a boy or even if I did have
another daughter
there wasn't any guarantee that she
would also be born in October in that
the same time of year so I guess I just
wanted to say sure even save a few of
your absolute favorite but I'm glad I
didn't and I think I think that my son
is
be not Pappas big sister family down hi
this is Rachel Richardson I'm from the
Dallas Texas area and I just wanted to
give you guys an idea everyone always
ask you know what to give her gifts
because they don't want to you know add
to someone else's extra stuff you know
and so I came up with an idea of making
videos for my family and posting them on
Facebook and there they're usually funny
videos and that's their birthday present
from us and they loved it they
absolutely loved it and they could share
it with their friends and it's just been
a big hit and it's free and it's kind of
like how you know giving the experience
that especially if you can't be with
that family member on their birthday all
right Joe that's almost it for this
episode before we close out rich I just
want to say thank you so much for being
a part of this we really appreciate it
I'm grateful for your friendships I'm
grateful for your knowledge I'm grateful
for that you exist in the world and
thank you for doing everything you do
man Yemen pretty good being
inspirational thank you guys it's uh
it's been a pleasure getting to know
both of you guys and and thank you for
letting me participate in in some of
your cool stuff and look you guys are
putting out an amazing message and to
the extent that I can help amplify that
and and further the reach of what you're
doing it's my pleasure to do so and it's
great to be here and talk to you guys
you're inspiring tons of people to be
more mindful about how they live what
they buy all that good stuff and it's
super cool to see people responding to
it so favorably thank you I appreciate
that and if you are listening this at
home you have a question for the
minimalists give us a call for zero six
two one nine seven eight three nine you
can also email a voice memo to podcast
at the minimalists comm and if y'all
leave here today with just one message
we hope it's this love people and use
things because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
alright let's dive into this patreon
and minimus